In this segment, we will first
discuss and compare different
views of the sum of independent
identically
distributed random variables.
And then, we will conclude
with a statement of the
central limit theorem.
So let X1 up to Xn be
independent identically
distributed random variables
that have a certain finite
mean and finite variance
that we'll denote by
mu and sigma squared.
In order to have a concrete
example in our hands, let us
assume that this random variable
has a distribution,
let's say, a PDF, that ranges
from minus 1 to plus 1 and has
a mean of 0.
Let us look at the sum of
these random variables.
The sum has a variance of n
times sigma squared, which
goes to infinity.
And correspondingly, the
standard deviation of this
random variable also
grows to infinity.
This random variable takes
values between
minus n and plus n.
And because the variance and
the standard deviation
increase, this means that for
larger and larger n, the width
of this distribution is going
to be larger and larger.
We can obtain a different view
of this sum if we divided by n
in, which case, we obtain
the sample mean.
In this case, the variance
goes to 0
as n goes to infinity.
And as a consequence, the
distribution is highly
concentrated around 0.
This is also what the weak law
of large numbers tells us.
The bulk of the distribution
is concentrated in an
arbitrarily small interval
around 0.
So this width becomes
smaller and smaller
as n goes to infinity.
So in this case, we obtain
a limiting distribution.
But this limiting distribution
is trivial.
It's degenerate.
It's all concentrated
on a single point.
How can we make it so that we
obtain a limiting distribution
that is more interesting?
The key is to divide not by
n, but to divide by the
square root of n.
This has the following effect.
The variance of this ratio
is calculated as follows.
We take the variance of the
numerator, which is n times
sigma squared.
And then we divide by
the square of this
number, which is n.
And therefore, the variance
is equal to sigma squared.
What's important here is that
the variance stays constant.
No matter what n is, the width
of this distribution is going
to be more or less the same.
The distribution itself might
change as n changes.
But the distribution--
at least in this case, where
we assume 0 mean, the
distribution stays in place.
It doesn't move to the
right or to the left.
And its width stays the same.
So one can wonder, in the limit,
as n goes to infinity,
does this shape start
to approach a
certain limiting shape?
And if it does, what is the
limiting shape that it
approaches?
The central limit theorem
will give us the
answers to these questions.
The setting for the central
limit theorem will be pretty
much the setting that we
were just discussing.
So we will be looking into the
case where we divide the sum
of the random variables by
square root of n, except for a
few additional twists.
Since this ratio has a variance
of sigma squared, it
would help to divide by a
further factor of sigma here
so that the variance is
going to become 1.
And there's another issue.
If the mean of the X's
is non-zero, then the
distribution is centered at
a quantity that keeps
changing with n.
So the distribution will be
drifting away from 0.
It's not staying in place.
And so it wouldn't
have any hope of
converging to something.
For this reason, instead of
looking at this ratio in
particular, what we do is we
first subtract the mean of the
sum, which is n times
the mean.
And then we divide by a further
factor of sigma.
This random variable that
we obtain here has nice
properties.
The mean of this random variable
is equal to 0,
because we did subtract
the mean of the X's.
And the variance of this random
variable is going to be
equal to 1.
The reason is that the variance
is the variance of
the numerator, which is n times
sigma squared, divided
by the square of the
denominator, which is also n
times sigma squared.
So as n changes, the
distribution of the random
variable Zn stays in place.
It has a mean of 0.
And its width, more or less,
stays the same, because we
have a constant variance.
We will compare this random
variable with a standard
normal random variable that has
0 mean and unit variance.
The central limit theorem states
the amazing fact that
as n goes to infinity, the
distribution of this random
variable converges to the
standard normal distribution
in the following sense--
that this probability here
converges to that probability
for any choice of little z.
Now, what we have here is just
the CDF of this random
variable, Zn.
So it tells us that the CDF
of the random variable Zn
converges to the CDF of
a standard normal.
And fortunately, for the
standard normal, the CDF is
available in tables.
So if we needed to calculate the
numerical value here, we
can just look up the
normal tables.
And this suggests an
approximation to this
probability for the case where
n is finite but large.
When n is large, we can
approximate this probability
by this probability on the
right, which we can find from
the normal tables.
The central limit theorem is
a very important result.
For this reason, we will spend
some time discussing how to
interpret it, what it means, how
we use it, and we will go
through a few examples to see
how we actually apply it.